[Music]
and ridiculous requests news hmm
submitted by with love from Albany oh
that's a Canada it could be New York oh
yeah
what about Albania no it could be okay
tonya harding's agents quit after she
requests to find reporters for asking
questions about her past
why is Tonya Harding relevant right now
her movie movie she's a gangster it was
great I'm not sponsored by a Tanya who
was she up against Tonya Harding and
Nancy Kerrigan now yeah we hate her now
Peter now the movie she was very serious
about it too right but but she got
injured by it was like a big thing in
the 90s right before and she was like
the big victim but there's a poor
perfect knee got hurt poor Nancy yeah
you know I watched a movie I forgot I
was a child all right so back in 1994
Tonya Harding's main team team
competitor Nancy Kerrigan she was
attacked by an assailant they busted her
kneecap damn that's a mafia [ __ ] yeah
and then so Tonya Harding received three
years probation 500 hours of community
service and a $100,000 fine for pleading
guilty to hindering prosecution of the
attackers oh wow and she wasn't a lot of
skate ever again that was the big one
exactly choose ban from figure skating
that makes sense to me a hundred percent
so what does she do to work she do
anything jeah
did you go watch the freakin movie it
was her mom was it her boyfriend her
idiot boyfriend and hit her yeah her
idiot boyfriend / husband / ex-husband
all all in one come I wish she go I
don't know what husband an ex well he ki
calm you they were together and then
they got married and they got wanted her
back yeah and he wanted her back and
[ __ ] and then hit his idiot friends and
him did it yeah then why does she plead
guilty yeah because she had thought
she'd get a lesser charge he did a plea
deal
then she also she never knew or
acquaintance movie she never knew that
they were gonna be busting her kneecaps
they just thought that they were gonna
be sending like they that's still bad
like a threat letter and sent her a
threat letter which turns out later it
was her own bodyguard I would love to
see Gino I would love to see perfect Gio
deal with the stresses of ice a figure
skating you think I'm perfect you know
you're acting perfect on me to
complement you dammit that sounds worse
than a beauty pageant drama [ __ ] yes
this is Tonya and this is Nancy what are
you doing a skate battle they're skating
again why are they all staged to go so I
get should have TMZ down here like it
looks like they're fighting I think
that's two separate pictures or is it
the scene they could be warming up oh
yeah
and then this is what Tonya looks like
now why is she a celebrity still because
she it was her story will be ha said one
of most famous people in the earth did
yeah she's super known super known all
over the world I just don't know yeah
and so this guy is her agents she looks
like a horse which says I would love to
hi Tonya is now goodbye Tonya
unfortunately we reached an impasse
today regarding how to treat the press
in the future her adamant and final
position is that reporters must sign an
affidavit saying they won't ask her
anything about the past or they'll be
fine 25 grand I mean that's all there is
to ask Tonya Harding print so I get what
he's saying obviously it doesn't work
that way and I have chosen to turn our
terminated our relationship I'm sad as I
write this with the same time I'm happy
that I had such an adventure with the
movie and with recreating a new positive
image for her in the public eye and I
sincerely wish for the best I thank you
all for fault followed me on this
adventure and offered me such
encouragement and support along the way
I'll never forget what else would they
ask about hey how's your day Tanya hey
Tanya we gardening anything right now I
know
I got I got to live yes she only wants
to talk about the movie and her future
project that's it was all about them
yeah exactly
people always say the new in future
projects and then and never nothing
never happens
where did he publicize it so he's
leaving he left he broke up with her
well isn't he the reason why she got in
trouble in the first place no no she
wasn't a part of it okay
because I feel like a lot of our viewers
don't know either is a pretty young
Gator I don't know you don't remember
this [ __ ] I remember that she got her
knee busted and Nancy was like oh poor
Nancy and I was in Tanya mean Tanya yeah
that was the thing mean Tanya literally
it angel I was like 10 or something like
that Niner I don't know I remember
reading or hearing about this on TV -
this movie was tight because it shows
how full of [ __ ] the media is and how
like bunch of scumbags they are they
shaped everything they shaped everything
and then they would like if she wouldn't
come outside for any reason for days on
end they couldn't get pictures of her
and [ __ ] and video of her they like
would get nude forever car to car towed
make a run after it and then they could
like take pictures of [ __ ] there pieces
of [ __ ] dude it's a she grew up in with
a really abusive mother and then her
husband was abusive it was just like not
a good life for her I saw the trailer
I was like man her mom acts like a
Russian coach it's funny how fun and
colourful their outfits are but then
deep down their souls brought me yeah
and the judges told her her outfit was
cheap and she had to make it because you
know in the morning we didn't have
$5,000 to pay for the outfit like it's
really expensive
it's bigger save $5,000 for an outfit
yeah I heard your score so it's not how
about is your score partner we used that
outfit dog how is that asleep sport
right like how is buying an outfit
designed and made by someone else a part
of your skull movie was good because it
was talking about how like you had to be
this ideal version of a woman including
like your clothes had to be perfect too
and it wasn't just about this
and she was like why can't it just be
about the sport like you should just
protested and went in a bikini
you know what's crazy and bodybuilding
the speedo that the dudes where they're
also judged on that and those things are
like two hundred dollars apiece and they
don't work in water
we're strictly bodybuilding speedos
people pay money for that gross ashes
don't like call me once they're like
those purple nutsack huggers they get
judged on their speedo yeah cuz it's
just like this it's a subjective sport
you know yeah it's up to the judges now
imagine that speedos five grand yeah no
I don't I don't like his speedos greens
not my color we all sports don't need
judges you have a score like 50 to 1050
wins
yeah but like the subjective sports they
get judged on all kinds of weird-ass
[ __ ] she would rebel by like painting
our nails beard colors and doing rock
music instead of like Malory no music
just FGM you saw to - yeah yeah you've
been the least opinionated about it
because I was thinking of London I
really loved Margot Robbie's performance
- like especially in the scenes where
like you could see like the inner
turmoil like we're just putting on the
makeup and then she's yeah oh my [ __ ]
she kept the core room scene was really
kill this movie when I want and tell
them that Nicky Wemo sent you 20 20 now
you're running for president yeah I'm
just
mind blown that they get judged on their
outfit like is it like that one didn't
have that many sequins yeah basically
and sparkly I liked that one also
unbelievably they judged her based on
what was happening in the news go figure
that sucks yeah exactly so she never had
a chance like well she was up in
competition it's just the politics of
the sport send me happen in the body
blade awesome so there's this guy his
name's Kai green he's arguably probably
the best I'm gonna be best body bows of
all time but because there's evidence of
him [ __ ] a grapefruit online yeah
would they would never just cuz he like
a lot of bodybuilders before they make
it they do like [ __ ] so nonchalantly
just [ __ ] just because they have a
video of a [ __ ] great
[ __ ] it like what what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that a lot of is like
bodybuilder physique dudes day before
they make it on it they got to do like
semi like gay type stuff know if [ __ ]
a grapefruit is a bad judge of character
or that it's gay yeah I was gonna say I
mean like it's called gay for pay were
you like you do like these cam shows and
then gay dudes pay oh that's so sexy so
we got to do this type of world of
sexual stuff okay and so like these big
no but there's a lot of these big-ass
federations or like leagues or whatever
they don't want a guy that is associated
with a grapefruit to be the poster boy
of that league his logo like that like
you should grand it in a way that makes
people go [ __ ] yeah yeah see the true
blues movies Lee no guy who [ __ ] a
great food never gonna make it at this
sport we gonna flush you out of your
green yeah that's awesome
that would be amazing can we write this
bow yeah he's a green right oh it is you
guys watch stringy things yeah you know
that buff ass oh that's him he's
crossing into movies now yeah there's a
black dude in street ponies yeah the
most recent season and that and that
like little mischievous group that
little Bunch where you love it with the
Indian girl oh yeah there's a crazy
mohawk least favorite part of the season
oh he's one of the outcasts junkies or
whatever yeah yeah oh when they won with
the outcasts I was like I'm not the
farmer in the beginning for that role we
just can't [ __ ] the grapefruit because
someone was like I want a jerk you long
time ago a long time ago and then so a
lot of these guys they'll do like Tropic
you know under from Down Under like that
type of stuff and then they and then as
they climbed the ranks when you hit the
olympia stage was like which is the
biggest stage for a bodybuilding Kyrene
has been runner up like four times even
when these clearly beat the other guys
when you say well what are they judge by
own body bone like size symmetry
conditioning which is like how lean they
are yeah and then
hey a recent senator was one of them art
which one that's what anemic he was a
governor governor oh whatever
yeah I don't know any of that stuff and
it's [ __ ] tragic
[Music]